special announcement coming in hot added
to rough and rowdy 19 December 9th I put
together one hell of a crew with calabas
fight companion show we will be watching
it live with the boys we're talking Theo
Von Joey Diaz Rampage Jackson myself
[Music]
oh goodness oh wow
what else you want tune in
turn
[Music]
a little bit of work man that don't
scare us
make plays break Lanes push way break
chains go hard kick ass take names
[Music]
I gotta go hard like I'm George Harrison
welcome to very very special episode of
Fight Night flashback I'm here with the
great Jeff die yes what's up my TV bro
thank you it was from uh you a couple
Panerai Bros oh yeah and we're Panera
Bros panorite twins uh it's a special
edition for you guys in honor of the uh
Cowboys fight companion collabing with
Barstool Sports on December 9th that's
Friday night at 5 p.m Pacific for rough
and rowdy 19 Seasons beating things we
have one hell of a crew we have Theo Von
Rampage Jackson and Uncle Joey Coco Diaz
[ __ ] is coming to the studio to
do a live fight campaign for Rough and
Ready 19 at 5 p.m Pacific Time on thick
boy YouTube so this is a very special
episode dedicated to my boys at bar
stool and rough and rowdy we're gonna go
over some of the best rough and rowdy
fights that they've had throughout the
whole 19 season so get your mind right
it's gonna be a little different than
usual Fight Night flashbacks let's get
into it hit it it's from Ralph rough and
rowdy one a five nine guy calls out a
six nine monster all right and it's
gonna surprise you guys West Virginia
sanctioned this fight which is shocking
but it's also West Virginia they're just
lucky to have teeth
oh my god oh boy and he does not the
fittest five nine guy no it is a sloppy
five nine but you know what he's he's
the he's the Rudy of rough and rowdy
he's that Rudy mentality yeah yeah he's
the Rudy meaning he's offsides too wait
so isn't this how UFC kind of started
because it would be like a karate guy
versus a street fighter yeah but this is
uh but this is a five nine guy with a
tank top there's a giant six nine guy
look at this guy like UFC was like you
know Campo karate versus boxing like
this is just yeah this getting some Air
Maxes and uh some you know basketball
shorts and a wife beater looking for a
little uh a little attention in a school
but he is you know I like his attitude
though that's that West Virginia dude
Something In The Water they just they
just believe they can do it man it's got
a real Russian vibe to him that guy yeah
but yeah let's play a game Russian or
West Virginia
especially since we can't hear him yeah
actually this guy looks familiar to me
yeah is that Travis Brown God he is
great for freaking eyebrows
check out the Brows on this guy but I
feel like the the stress is more on the
giant six nine guy because you're
fighting this West Virginia meatball
yeah you got it you gotta root for that
meatball if you're in there who's
rooting for this guy especially why does
he have low top shoes on well these guys
don't fight I also like the diversity in
the audience for West Virginia
yeah look at that it looks like a trump
convention
oh wow oh well neither can whoa big boy
is just swinging
he's swinging Like Bugs Bunny I like how
the ref's just dead serious like dude
just let him go
oh
a lot of Rights I don't think there's a
lot of a lot of head swinging
he's just swinging go to the body young
man oh you got clip there
these are Big these boys are this is
like a Dave and Buster's fight but not a
good one hard to watch well I'm really
rooting for the little West Virginia
Rudy here he keeps getting tagged though
he could put his head too much he's
gonna he's gonna lose his head look at
that now if this was basketball it'd be
a different story oh his ass cheeks his
ass is hanging out nervous he's like I
didn't want anyone to know I'm wearing a
song
here we go
oh my God the Kitty has a chin on him
now why would he agree to this
his mom's like get him and I'm sure
she's not saying friendly things about
the tall fella I'm just gonna what do
you uh what do they get what do they win
uh Pride really and and some exposure
from Barstool oh no you probably some
dope Barstool Merch this has got this
would be because you can't they're not
pro so it'd be a sanctioned amateur like
smoker fight
oh boy and yeah then you do the fun ring
girl thing uh cough ring girl
and the in the round it's one minute
rounds and one minute rest or they get
two minute rests it's one and one
one and one that is lit this guy's gonna
need a lot more rest he said I'm tired
man he said I'm tired man yeah you're
not fighting it right
he goes can I get a helmet this guy is
swinging
and I love it no no mouthpieces either
that guy's mouthpiece West Virginia
doesn't he goes does it matter yeah also
he would have real trouble with a real
fighter if he's have if he didn't knock
this kid out in the first round yeah
yeah yeah
this guy this guy gets asked what by
Lamar Odom
rest in peace all right let's do this
for every fight could Jake Paul beat
them Jake Paul would beat both of them
at the same time I like that yes
although good question though look at
this heart I like how he bends down at
the waist oh he's
I love that the Aspen whoever his uh
fighting coach was was like just keep
bending over and turning around dude
he's getting lit up oh he's on uppercut
weird uppercut dude very effeminate
uppercut he was up hey hey I think he's
a little sugar in his tank with that up
it's a weird uppercase yeah I didn't
like it but his hey dude tighten up he's
so wide like even the West Virginia kids
at least throwing down the pipe this
basketball guy right which is soon
basketball he's looking he's looking at
the side his mom said throw throw the
one two combo son throw it son just do
it for your daddy whoever he is dude if
you're a dad I'm sure he's in the crowd
somewhere
here we go I can't believe this kid
hasn't been knocked out yet
the crowd's like Jesus maybe that's why
this is in the Highlight Reel is if this
kid wins oh I'm gonna be shocked this
kid's chin is nutso this is a miniature
this is a mini me Roy Nelson yeah the
boxing gloves are heavy for him he can't
even guard his face anymore the hands up
is the least of his worries look he's
got his hands he's oh the toughest kid
on the western playground my God
how do you think these rafts feel like
[ __ ] I can't believe I'm doing this one
two can we just
uh the rain girl's back in
two tires oh the the the the West
Virginia kid doesn't win oh wow it said
surprising this is not surprising I
would have I would have bet a lot of
money wouldn't answer the Bell see you
thought it was like Rudy turns out it is
yeah like the real Rudy yeah also a
quitter like Rudy yeah
oh he just killed he doesn't get up
he's like what what am I doing I didn't
think this would be so hard is what he's
saying
I thought fighting would be easy I
thought this was out of the crowd who
called out the big guy it's probably
like I thought it was gonna be a WWE
thing man oh my gosh
look at what and if that guy do you even
celebrate like do you go out and get
drinks with your Bros you got to just
say oh what'd you do I beat up a five
six West Virginia kid I hit a guy so
many times he quit oh wow man that's
been oh wow this guy's gonna be able to
take a shot first time ever small person
match-up 4-2 smidge the doorman verse
4-3 Ballin King Pablo smidge was once
the title holder of the Mattis mother
trucker dwarf that's their wording not
mine the bmfd from rough and rowdy 10.
let's take it all the way back to rough
and rowdy 10. I like the nickname smidge
smidge yeah I like smidge that's a
function King is a little much for uh
for a dwarf both these small guys have
great teeth
who do you think has the reach Advantage
who cares those numbers would be
hilarious oh damn look at the Posse
though oh yeah he's got a lot of friends
I do wish Ruff and Rowdy bring up like
tail of the tape 4-3 reach 13. yeah
exactly well here's the thing this they
should do this I don't see why you
couldn't have a dwarf versus a dwarf and
UFC
because they can't fight they could but
they could train to fight sure I mean a
small age I'm sure there's some
dagestanding and small people out there
that would rip our dicks off
look at this this isn't funny I like how
the crowds on their feet join us for all
the wrong reasons also some Thanksgiving
hats in the crowd
you see that got a turkey on his head oh
there's a tail of the tape there you go
bar stool age 20 oh they took it off 24
was it 23 or 33.
33 in small years is like 93. look at
those ponchos oh boy go to the body
oh he is also it looks like he's
laughing hell yeah he's having to get oh
show him in the oh God the Ollie's
Shuffle on that ass these punches are
not who you got here Jeff I'm taking the
uh the Asian fella I gotta take it I
gotta take the shirtless guy I don't
even know which yeah the shirtless guy
oh
he's laughing the King guy
the other which one's King the guy with
the the shirt the shirt the smidge
smidge got smidge is built like a
stingray
all traps smidge is in it you know oh
smidges look he's focused
they should have a dwarf riff too
shouldn't they just so you know I think
so now do you think the ref when he was
getting into referee was like this
probably wasn't one of these patrons it
feels a little weird yeah I thought I
was gonna do Tyson Holyfield mass square
gun I took this gig thinking it wouldn't
be like this I was hoping that the worse
I get a Jake Paul fight something
Nate Robinson versus yeah I'll take
Aaron Carter tomorrow
this is Rock Bottom what could Logan
Paul beat these guys
now these are Showmanship smidge is a
showman now he's showing I think it's
punch right in the face yeah oh he's
lighting him up though he was trying to
distract him with that thing
oh there you go not a lot of head
movement either
maybe he's I don't know physics very
well but and maybe because their arms
are so short like it's hard to get any
punch behind it like that generate power
yeah you're not mad at the ring girls
I've never seen a top like that I
thought she was
coming out of it she's not she's just no
it's just outside that's pretty lit
and you see they showed a king looking
at the girl
he's just staring okay he's all right
right right yeah that's right that's
what I'm here for
there's a smidge he's trying to get that
second round 20 minutes
I like how the crowds on their feet dude
oh he's a showman good footwork watched
a lot of Ali tape just combos body body
look at him build the body oh body top
smidge is gonna win this fight you know
why you need a door for referees because
the referee keeps blocking The View
that's a fair point too big all right
here we go
hey King get your head in the game this
ain't funny I wonder if these are 10
ounce
gloves
smidge is doing work dude this is great
he knows he's got just throwing bombs
playing his bomb boom boom
you love to see oh my God that was a
good one it doesn't seem like it's
affecting them
oh uppercut
all punches the same between these two
I'd love to add like some uppercut was
it or the jab I wish they added sound
effects every punch like
on the body though at least
he trained for this
King's like I'm not taking my shirt off
yeah I like that guy's enthusiasm
butt shot
all right getting some water one minute
break from any stat it up dude
oh yeah exclamation what is that a
semicolon I don't know what that means
maybe it's because of his Anatomy he has
a semicolon
a small guy
that's where I thought Smith was going
to take this body body then up top he'll
he's trained for it
I mean he I think he's gonna win he's
whipping this dude's ass worse than the
six nine guy did the the short fat West
Virginia kid
also I don't think these punches are
affecting him much he's Landing more
King I don't know if we're gonna see a
knockout King you got dreads for this
come on dude come on get your [ __ ]
together what are we doing we paid for
this oh I like that I love the Sprint oh
look at this this dude this has a very
Pride feel to it Don fries to get down
dude smidge was like we're ending this
thing
King's regretting it King's like Jesus
take it easy man
I'll tell you what King's hanging in
there though yeah he's just like smidge
maybe if I absorb every punch they'll
just hooks are a smidge pick me as the
winner
I like the rain girls on their cell
phones got some body shots in on that
Ringo's playing candy the rainbows
aren't real no they're playing Candy
Crush they're like we just graduated
Community College
body oh he's got that up on the back too
well I'll tell you right now our boy
smidge can be exhausted yeah he's gonna
be gassed this is a fight for the ages
though I like he's got him on the ropes
I mean he's beating the [ __ ] out of him
and the smidge was the heavyweight
champion he's a little Fujita it to him
man a little pride Fujita days he knows
guys got it you see this guy sucks every
small guy has an ass facts oh yeah
science I watched that show Little Women
or whatever on TLC oh yeah where it's
just all the whole stars are all these
ugly and they're they're always twerking
all of them they're always like like oh
we got that's right they get paid to
twerk they're twerking anytime that
there's like a moment where it's not
funny on the show and they know the
camera did you start like tweak Twerk it
it's like yeah it's easy to twerk and I
love it wait what happened here
uh just one of those things where
there's no loser
what is this oh look at the iPhone is
belt what is this Seattle
it's Portland can't both win oh no I
think that they're just saying is it
soccer no our our guy won little fujito
look at them they're like they're so
cute they treat him like children like
can we buy one yeah
our boy reigning champ dude reigning
champ watch your [ __ ] mouth Jeff
look at she's gonna flash was that what
was about to happen
and a crown that's a bit it gets dressed
like a nun how about the math scientists
in the back with the bow tie
that is much
got a scepter I mean this is he's going
full King yes Conor McGregor rough and
rowdy oh so we've been using the wrong
name smidge was the other guy maybe
no is his name King I mean he's got a
candy robe and he got a
scepter
interesting
interesting
I've been calling him
yeah me too I thought because it was in
the thumbnail it says yeah
King Pablo oh he's probably King Pablo
because the guy with the dredge probably
King Pablo in my defense I don't know a
lot about this guy's career
in my defense I just started following
this guy I missed the Netflix documents
yeah I don't know which one's smidge and
which ones well let's move on to rough
and rowdy eight
you got rough and rowdy eight let me see
the info on that Mike oh boy oh god
let's take a little break from chat with
my boy Jeff dye talking all things
Ruffin Rowdy make sure you watch it
December 9th on YouTube thick boy we got
Theo Vaughn Rampage Jackson Joey Coco
Diaz and myself are all tuning in to the
rough and rowdy 19 Seasons beatings but
listen up listen up thick Fam I'm here
to talk about my friends at Rogue if
you're a regular viewer of any of my
shows
social media you already know how much I
love Rogue nicotine I go nowhere without
these cans these cans I use their
pouches every single day I form my mouth
as we speak I use them on my podcast at
the gym when I'm driving on stage off
stage in The Green Room
everywhere I mean everywhere my favorite
flavor is the Apple Apple's my favorite
I like the mango the lemon drop the
berries not bad I dig all them
Cinnamon's pretty intense but I dig it I
can't get enough of them I started with
mango and then I just started branching
out they got Wintergreen peppermint
honey lemon they got it all the flavor
of Rogue destroys anything out there I'm
telling you that's why I started with
Rogue I asked them to jump on my
sick boy team because I use them so much
I went hey it just makes sense let's be
friends and here we are beyond the
pouches Rogue also makes other great
nicotine products like gum tablets and
lozengers however you want to get your
nicotine if you don't like the the
pouches you can get it in pill form
lozengers they got it all gum they got
it all and I can take them anywhere I
want on the plane comedy clubs no
restrictions Rogue is my go-to source
for nicotine whenever I'm performing I
love it I reach out to them be part of
the shows as I told you guys because I
use Rogue more than any other product in
my life it's my favorite if you want to
try the pouches like me or gums or
tablets everyone try your nicotine go to
Rogue nicotine.com use the code rogue20
that's rogu20 for 20 for your order
again that's Rogue 20 for 20 soft your
order of the best the best nicotine on
the planet we're talking about Road
nicotine baby underage sales prohibited
warning this product contains nicotine
right nicotine is an addictive chemical
for more information visit
roguenicotine.com this app is soda Fight
Night flashback is also brought to you
by on it and they have one hell of a
deal going on you better hurry up though
there's only a few days left to get on
this big sale it start off with Black
Friday when to freaking Cyber Monday and
here we are kids the end of the weekend
they're still giving you these hot deals
I'm talking about 25 off supplements up
to 60 off door busters 10 Fitness
kettlebells uh battle ropes they got the
freaking steel Club Macy's they got 20
off nutrition we're talking about
protein powder protein bars elk bars elk
butter we got it all we got it all twins
off apparel and Gear Fit yourself
Digital streaming Fitness if you want to
get your thick ass in shape you can do
it from your phone at the crib they have
it all and there's never been this big
of a sale on it 25 off that includes
Alpha Brain I'm usually pitching on 10
off Alpha Brain not anymore 25 off we
got you guys you want the the real deal
make sure you use audit.com
job as chaub when you enter in your cart
make sure you use audit.com enjoy the
big old sale from audit audit.com
this one's gonna be good uh so before we
move on you got state champion wrestler
versus a hillbilly Sapphire a toothless
woman from the backwoods of West
Virginia my favorite gives a young
Fighter the business this is Throwback
to rough and rowdy eight hit it
so yeah just because she can wrestle
doesn't mean she's gonna be able to box
uh I think she's uh the the one from
West Virginia yes what happened whoa
wrestlers what happens when you get I
mean maybe just because no teeth I mean
why let me just keep going dude like she
doesn't look that old I mean she doesn't
look like a 18 year old but how do you
lose the teeth that soon
you know this thing's interesting
because they're showing that lady with
no teeth and then they showed the
wrestler and I don't maybe it's just
because I was looking at Jennifer Wright
Sapphire for so long and then they show
Cassandra like she was she the hottest
girl in the world yeah yeah you know
it's like well I've been in a desert for
30 days and she's the first woman I've
seen before I talk to any woman in
society ever I just want to watch 10
seconds of Jennifer Wright yeah me too
man because before everything I'll be
such a sweet guy you're gorgeous she's
like really yeah I've been watching
Jennifer's bright videos oh what's
Jennifer right before I go to any bar
you want to hook up Victoria's Secret
models in here also this but like I said
this just proves like wrestling means
nothing in boxing well nothing matters
at all when they're from West Virginia
she just threw a punch like this you
know what I think I've seen this me
really oh my god dude West Virginia it's
the wall oh my god dog she's getting uh
oh that's a salt lady she's hated hot
chicks her whole life dude she has those
prison Dickies on too son dude prison
Dickies that's my wife that guy's like
get her honey and this is Barstool so
everyone else in the crowd if maybe the
wrestler wins we'd see your tits
you know they're they're everyone's
rooting for the hot chick
but look at West dude the hot chicks
head Mountain Mama she's like what the
[ __ ] did I sign up for and then someone
should come hey she's no teeth from West
Virginia what were you thinking she has
nothing to lose yeah you've been
wrestling your whole life and going to
bed at 10 p.m she's drinking moonshine
before the match she drank and type out
of moonshine stepped out here on the
[ __ ] field also she knew she was
gonna fight oh she wore those pants yeah
dude those prison Dickies and a belt
no sponsors I noticed either no no no
mouthpiece for what how does it stay in
yeah mouthpiece as long as they put them
off these issues for what yeah how's it
going to stay will they protect you all
right you're fine get in there yeah you
got gum mouthpie to protect my gums just
give me a stick just give me a stick of
gum I already got gingivitis come on
look at that right there on the chin
dude so accurate
I like this part right here what you got
on the ropes what no this is all prison
First Team all prison I did that's for
sure shank in that girl and then the co
comes over and goes hey hey hey come on
you know dude she has the same haircut
from the Mexican kid from Dangerous
Minds see that shot she was taking a
personal out there oh dude this is She's
Out For Blood yeah the rest she's gonna
be pissed when they stop the fight she's
like wait I haven't killed her yet
like no no goes to judge's decision
she's mad at it look at that dude her
cardio someone test her for EPO
meanwhile this wrestler is like holy
[ __ ] yeah no steroids a lot of meth in
those results
[Laughter]
like a lot of a lot of Bud Light stuff
not really against the fighting rules oh
she caught up there the the wrestler
just needs to she needs to be more
active and quit holding back if I was
just wrestler because I'd get on the
microphone say if you guys tell anybody
about this I'll [ __ ] kill you
don't put this on TV
move and hey purse God and you know what
makes it worse her hair's not tied back
so it looks like her natural's getting
you know what I'll say you know we
didn't foresee this happening but I
think she could beat Jake Paul this West
Virginia lady uh Jeff I think she could
beat me yeah she's a beast dude yeah I
grabbed my hands full it's also in your
mind psychologically like some Gypsy
Woman without teeth going hey he won't
beat me like the wrestlers rattled
it looks really bad when you're getting
Molly walked out there she's bleeding
she's got free life she do she's so sad
and you know this is you know how
embarrassed she is right now oh yeah I
would be she's like but I'm hot I'll be
more embarrassed with her Corner man who
had the Affliction shirt and double
piercings on his ears oh dude she is 60
days in Molly 60 days 60 days in exactly
come get some girl
when you like you're on that show and
you go well I'm just trying to lay low
but I think this one West Virginia
chick's on to me because I know
you
were
oh my God stop the fight pretty cool
yeah this is the best fight ever I want
to see her knock out king whatever his
name is that little person oh King Pablo
yeah King Pablo or Smith I'd rather see
him now I got both of them yeah dude
she's watching smidge get punched yeah
me too dude but this chick would dude
crush it she's not my problem is she's
not even breathing hard she's still more
punches than a Nate Diaz fight she's not
even sweating she's also the best
fighter ever to have zero groupies
foreign
sloppy tits hanging out just going I'll
beat everybody them 60 day in tits man I
like the armband tattoo oh I didn't see
that throwback very Pamela Anderson the
barbed wire yeah she's very Pam Anderson
that's as close she's gonna get to pound
look at this guy Will Ferrell's rephant
huh no it's his brother from Step
Brothers yeah
all right here we go we're gonna do
another round right
or her Corner dude her eyes she's just
like she just tweaking out so who else
wants some when you said like she thinks
it's supposed to be to the death I like
that's it couldn't be more true oh dude
she doesn't understand like this is
attempted murder dude you know how
grateful she is just to have a roof
overhead some AC yeah she's still
fighting on the yard in the [ __ ]
burning she's like the people giving her
attention because she's normally asking
for change we just ignore her dude she's
had such death in her eyes she's
punching like this
it's weird to see her without a
Rottweiler on a rope
here we go
I wonder if she's gonna gas out this
this poor this poor girl now she's 18.
damn this even her Jabs or not that ref
said I will stop this man for you that's
great we don't want her to look like you
is that her boyfriend
no the guy with the goggles this girl's
so embarrassed now the good thing is the
good thing is I would I would I would
doubt Amy's friends what her name is is
not gonna watch this
so probably like her friends oh yeah her
like girl group she's telling them you
probably hey girl coming over for
mojitos whatever tonight and she's gonna
learn like damn what happened to you
he's like are you jumped out of Target
car accident car accident wow and that
car accident is that hillbilly Sapphire
West Virginia car accident that was sick
dude I'd watch that back to back oh dude
I'd watch that over any UFC Main Event
all right let's move on hopefully he
gets better last break kids before we
end this episode This Very Special
Edition bar stool rough and rowdy we are
here to tell you about a little thing
called Kratom that's right grab them all
right I used to fire up my brains my
Limitless pill if you're out there and
you've been trying CBD and you just got
remember CBD we really don't know what
to expect and then boom cbd's everyone
can trust it that's my friends at happy
hippo if I'm gonna use kratom I use it
all the freaking time you gotta use
somebody that you trust you got to use
the best creative on the planet I use
their High concentrated shots the Cherry
shots before I do shows before I do
anything I'm pounding that stuff I'm so
love it gets my brain firing all
cylinders and you guys know I need all
the help I can alright so if you want to
try the best focused product on the
planet and it's all natural visit
happyhippo.com use promo code thick boy
with three C's you 20 saw for Life use
that code as many times you want shoot
with your aunt your uncle your cousin
with no teeth share it around that thick
boy for 20 off for life that's the promo
code thick boy twin style for Life visit
happyhippo.com promo code dick boy twin
stop for Life use as much as you want
best grandmother Planet happy hippo hey
fam it's never too early to play a
little holiday music all right it's
never I mean
if you do it before Thanksgiving you're
you're weird but it's after Thanksgiving
so go ahead and play those Jingle Bells
in your mouth all right it's never too
early to start thinking about gifts all
right whether it's for a friend or a
friend of yours in your pants your dad
I would say your mom if they have hairy
shoulders uh stepdads good buddy maybe
got a man's out there all right it's
time to make this season extra special
with my friends at manscaped you're a
little drummer boy well thank you guys
because you need to get that new
lawnmower 4.0 to avoid another silent
night in the sack that's right then you
add manscape's top of the line shower
products to have the people thinking all
I want for Christmas is that thick
hairless dude over there all right Santa
cares about your big sack and so should
you look nice when you get naughty and
get free shipping and 20 off at
manscape.com
it's the Platinum package 4.0 the
One-Stop shop for every bro who deserves
it all it's everything you need to help
you Deck the Halls from your face do
your balls just in time for the
mistletoe seas and fam in this Platinum
package you're gonna get that freaking
lawnmower 4.0 body trimmer and you get
the weed whacker no nose ear hair
trimmer feature all right we got you
there comes a little light on you and
then you get the Ultra Premium body wash
Ultra Premium two in one shampoo
conditioner we got you there and then
also you also get a little bit of
smelling help here you get some spelling
help with the crop preserver it's
deodorant uh for your nuts and then you
get crop reviver it's ball toner you
know soon they get all sweaty and they
stick to your leg not anymore with
manscaped all right so nothing is going
to make your men in your life more happy
all right so for the perfect stocking
stuffer add in the brand new body buffer
incredible body scrubber that makes
exfoliating easy all right if you want
all this you want to give the perfect
gift for that man in your life or men's
in your life go I don't like men's
anymore get 20 off and free shipping at
manscape.com job that's 20 off and free
shipping at menscape.com
manscape get your jingle balls ready for
the holidays I don't like men's anymore
you have trapzilla the male stripper
insane yeah oh rubbing her face
trapzilla so his traps are rejecting his
wiener uh trapzilla male stripper also
arm wrestler on the side okay versus a
construction worker I'm just going on a
limb out here and I'll take the
construction I'll take the armrest I'm
taking the construction workers always
checked yeah I know but they're kind of
you know I guess Jack means nothing in
this well it could mean some but also I
mean strippers I guess they have Carter
because they're rubbing their dicks in
the face yeah they gotta do the dumb
absolutely look what my I don't even
know what ABS do construction worker
just like you know construction worker
just needy strong arms I can lift things
what do my abs do no it's your core bro
this is the debut of trapzilla the male
stripper who's fighting Dax he's
fighting on Friday so let's let's let's
see how trapzilla's gonna do that's
gonna depend if I bet on or uh on the
fight companion Friday December 9th at 5
pm on thick boy YouTube In Cahoots with
bar stool Sports and rough and rowdy so
that better not be this stripper oh that
is trap Zill I think trap Zillow dude
male stripper in what trap house this
dude is jacked I gotta take trapsulin
that's the construction work dude
dude who wants a lap dance from the
fight he looks like an extra from
American listen if you like American
History X well you're getting lectured
about KKK history this is your guy
which which muscle is your trap
okay he's got traps this guy's got
construction worker
oh god dude the balls on these guys that
do this and also the the and you know
the male strippers and come with the
[ __ ] fire he has the dope ass kicks
on that guy I do not the baggy shorts on
if this guy wins I'll be shocked I take
traps even a trap Zilla loses I'll be
like impossible this is rigged
anyways I gotta be honest uh dude the
farmer's tank he's about in the sun oh
God this is about to be brutal oh I'd
rather I only see trap Zilla versus the
meth Queen
oh yeah see this oh see the Trap still
looks like he's been in some fights
before too yeah at a strip club I'm sure
people making fun of him get off my wife
or just those punches I mean he's
swinging oh man he has attitude too the
construction worker's like dude come on
man that's the best fighter we've seen
so far in these little Clips besides our
hillbilly Sapphire now I'm just gonna
I'm just gonna go on a limb on this and
uh Dave port and I don't get mad I
assume there's no usada testing Yeah
Yeah from the from the meth girl no
teeth to trapzilla
if you're a male stripper you're on PDS
right you're like baseball in the early
2000s exactly yes but no big deal yeah
be cool man everybody's Lance Armstrong
the male stripper who's not using
bumpers and boosters where the hell
zippy zappies
look at this guy I tell you what though
that construction worker lands one if
but that's the thing it's gonna you
didn't earn it if he wins this he didn't
earn it he got he got the lottery got
one on the button they can't even get up
he's doing a lot of work well he's he's
just more exhausted and punched he's
been laying oh Jump Around jump around
all day he's exhausted
dude he's playing concrete and just a
straight wife beetle look at that hand
let me keep that shirt on dude this male
stripper got body for days
this dude is bodied up yeah but also
like I was gonna not like him because
he's a stripper but yeah me too but then
when I saw him I was like oh I guess if
he doesn't look like most strippers no
he looks like he'd be a fun guy to hang
out with yeah this guy looks angry yeah
stripper AKA Hell's Angel this guy is
Jack guys like me I run my mouth a lot
you know so I like hanging out with guys
like that who are like hey my guy Jeff
gets to say whatever yeah you don't say
whatever he wants man
they got it like your little friend you
go shut up he's with me okay she's got
some spunk take it easy for my boy trap
Zilla gets off that stage and starts
dancing right now he goes she can't
dance she's like you think that's
dancing give me that goddamn number two
she doesn't even have an eight pack
starts body rolling although she's
really into it I like enthusiasm she's
got her handle on her bikini bottoms
her Twitter handle that's poor
construction worker man this guy didn't
know what he what did they not show him
who they're gonna fight before the day
um
dog
the construction worker his boys when he
gets back to that work they're like bro
there's certain guys in the world too
that you can just like I don't know if
it's true maybe this is a stereotype but
there's certain guys you just see and
you go I think this guy's been in some
fights like just like in life you're
saying with the stripper yeah like he's
got that face and look of like a guy
that's like yeah I'm ready to go yeah
he's been through some stuff he also has
a defend his job all the time it's even
shitty gets from being a male stripper
yeah but because I just assumed male
strip was like weiner that's it but they
don't describe Zilla he's beating the
stereotype that was it it who else wants
something he got him in the chin but
forward bro who the hell is Godzilla
fighting on next Friday December pick
our guy hope he's fighting the math lady
you can't prepare she has volume dog she
doesn't have the same power she has
volume yeah she has better cars than
anybody we've seen I like that move yeah
the 60 days in uppercut this guy is not
gonna be able to go back to the
construction site no man what am I gonna
do
I mean he just got molly walked he's
like he's just seeing the guy though
yeah his name's trap Zilla and then I'm
like right right right we looked into
him he's a male stripper yeah we got
your back we're gonna go down to Cherry
Pop tonight for you look at his eyes oh
my God
that was the moment where he was like
forget boom straight on that's the
beauty of it
dude trap Zilla is jacked
oh that saved his life right there on
that one that would have been knock him
to the moon like you're hitting your
stepson boom it'd be cool if trapzilla
did like a cool dance like at least the
worm or something yeah dude though do it
you know I love when big thick dudes
they seem to sound so homosexual I love
when big thick dudes dude the robot hell
yeah or any kind of thing yeah it's
funny when they take their shirt off but
that's the last one let me see what we
got here Mike you got Bobby lights out
Lang who's fighting December 9th he's
fighting our boy uh the cornerback
Pac-Man Jones we'll see how he does
about Pac-Man I'll let you know so Bobby
Lang Ruff and Rowdy this is Debut uh
he's eight no and now he's the
heavyweight champion from rough and
rowdy 10. all right and he's again he's
fighting December 9th so he got
trapzilla and Lang you don't usually see
the basketball jersey and uh pinky
blinders hat on the same yeah that's the
same very Boston you see that a lot what
stadium is that behind him yeah unless
you're Mark Wahlberg you're punching
Asian guys in the face wait is this the
winner is that other guy the winner
which one the first guys that first
guy's heavyweight champ
why does he have some sort of like
boxing background or like a fighting oh
look it's Gillette Stadium yeah there
you go very Boston of them
yeah they let him on the lot to shoot
his promo
here we go
Mike uh Mike loose looser or Lucifer oh
these boys are going at it nope it's
over that Crowd Oh my God he's running
dude this that prison yard fight huh
I usually frown upon it unless you're um
a white wrapper right or riffraff that's
what I'm saying if you're riff raff I'm
all about it but you're not
he also has a very UH 60 days in Vibes
not playing around
this guy the guy with the corners ran
from him
he goes oh I didn't think it was going
to hurt like that also who goes into a
boxing match with a shiner that means he
was training hard he's training hard
dude
the the cornrows boys all bleeding
already looking on his kidney dude from
those bodies there's no way they can
keep this pace the body shots actual
like marks or
bruises on I'm sure those aren't
tattoosier no look at us back oh I see
it yeah it's got like it looks like you
do that suction cup thing that hot
chicks do right there look at that thing
that's how bad that body shot hurt he's
bruising up from it
you got through a peace sign like a 14
year old what are the tickets for this
10 bucks 20 bucks
um yeah I forget what it is
be fun to go watch people how fun would
this be yeah I can't wait for the
campaign how fun is it gonna be
different than a real like UFC card we
gotta like pay attention like this one
you can watch have fun with you got guys
like you know also this is like the
smartest thing to bet on ever because
who knows I don't think there's lines on
this I mean we met with each other with
each other yeah but like DraftKings
didn't give me odds on this well how
could you ever well math girl would be
like minus nine dollars look at his back
when he runs away yeah he's been getting
tore up that's the worst place to get
hit in your kidney
this guy's like all right listen man
um there's so much to cover in a minute
just don't get hit he's going is it too
late to uh rethink this
I didn't think this pale guy would be so
good at this
the rest the the Champs dad maybe
they could keep this pace because the
rounds are so short one minute dude even
for a minute I could
find a professional level it'd be tough
though oh he rocked him there this guy's
afraid for his life he's got adrenaline
energy
yeah he looks he is jacked too he's got
like a weird head for that body I want
to see him versus uh Mike Zilla do you
know what the problem is against uh
Pac-Man is if you don't have a lot of
experience this guy just it's all about
like who's the toughest person you know
what I'm saying so it's like bare
Knuckles a lot of tough
I gotta imagine Pluto most people don't
know what it's like to just get punched
right on the face no and this guy
encourages it he is just if you're if
UFC you know what it's like but like if
you're these guys maybe they're like
that stupid West Virginia kid that went
against the six nine kid dude you gotta
the construction work you've been
punched before it's gonna hurt this
guy's just flopping all over he doesn't
know what planet he's on
he's so exhausted the problem is the
pace this guy keeps the ref goes what
what's today's date and he goes West
Virginia and they go no no no no no
that's not where we're
we're in New England okay I'll make the
question easier where are we uh Earth
all right you're good kid get in there
this guy's gonna hit you again
yes the pace homeboy sets that's why
he's the champ it'd be a nightmare to
deal with if you're not experienced I
can't believe this is legal
in fact if these were dogs it wouldn't
be legal no you can't do this with dogs
that's Michael Vick foreign
you see the it's the pace like you can't
get a break you can't you can't get
situated for like there's no game plan
with this yeah you just have to stick
and move but it's only a minute freaking
long so it's me this gets me tough to be
I would go on a limb I'd probably assume
he beats Pac-Man if he keeps the same
Pace I'm not like scared I assume he
beats Pac-Man do we have any footage on
Pac-Man Jones fighting we have the one
where you uh father's girlfriend right
just kidding edit that
pac-manual I don't know I don't know how
he would be as a fighter who knows it
doesn't matter because if you don't
experience this guy's Pace it's his
freaking pacing although he's getting
lit up here you kind of see but see how
it just goes forward
this I really think it's been over for a
few rounds look at this what was that
movie James Franco was that was it
spring breakers jiggly that's what he
looks like
oh that wasn't riffraff no but Riff Raff
sued him because he said you stole my uh
identity
that dude got knocked down and then got
hit so bad he sat down and then his head
went in the guy's lap he turned around
went body is bruised
you think he goes to Red Robin after
this they go you think you're still
ready to see like you can keep going and
he's like yes and they go what a liar
oh my God it's over it's the pacing and
then once the guy's decent save this
guy's life that was just this is this
guy's uh first match in rough and rowdy
right yeah and now he's champ right now
I want to see if these girls are digging
it
I want that a turtleneck gun yeah if
it's your girl or if it's your guy
winning that good right here watch this
sucks that guy's girlfriend nope boom
right here look boom that guy's
girlfriend's in jail somewhere yeah yeah
there's no he's
boom boom that guy with the braids is a
terrible fighter yeah
you can put all the tattoos on you you
want it's not going to change the if you
can fight or not yeah you can put it you
can put a wing on a Civic
oh that's good how'd you feel out there
oh he's a lot shorter unless that guy's
Dikembe Mutombo he's a lot shorter
Pac-Man Jones oh it's this guy I know
Pac-Man Jones uh the airport guy
oh he knocks this dude out but the
airport guy was asking for it yeah oh
for sure I was on Pac-Man's side for
sure I've wanted to do that a billion
times
wow so our boy Bobby lights out Lang
with his intense intense pace is
fighting December 9th Ruffin Rowdy bar
stool thick boy it will be live on thick
boy at 5 p.m Pacific with Theo Von
Rampage Jackson Uncle Coco Diaz
[ __ ] you got trapzilla the male
stripper I wish he would fight Bobby
lights out Lang but it's not happening I
wouldn't mind if hillbilly Sapphire came
back uh our state champion wrestler just
needs to stay out of it uh smidge and
King Pablo yeah sorry about the names
mess up there but King Pablo but also we
saw it the whole way yep yep and then
the five nine guy just not for you my
man but that's it kids hopefully you
enjoyed that insane rough and rowdy 19
teaser season beatings it is going down
that is next Friday that is the December
9th 5 p.m Pacific Time on thick boy
YouTube go watch it buy the pay-per-view
watch with us the boys again theovan and
Joey Coco Diaz Rampage Jackson myself
will be live thick Boy YouTube
season beatings rough Friday 19 go get
it Jeff you're the best thanks brother
you're in the thick boys
like subscribe comment
and God bless America well that's not my
big one just kidding